aaf
髪の毛切りてまた何してるの今かなぁ
動画を取りませんお値段肇社長ですこの家に住んでからもどれだけの日が経ったことが
あって外ずつになったっけここ
2015年の6月だからもう三大すぐ3年ダーダーここに住み始めてもうすぐ3年に
なりそうでございますでめちゃくちゃいいですよ引っ越さないが引っ越さないなりの
理由があって今僕はここに
います本来だったらもう東京でお仕事が多いんで東京に引っ越すべきなんですけども
まぁそれははねのけでも僕はここにいたいというかあるんです
まあほんと大家さんがいい人だしこのをいつも広くて兄し東京もまぁなんや海へ新幹線
で1時間ぐらい少し
近所にでご家族の方が住んでるんですけどもなんかその人からもう顔育つに手紙が来
たりしてなんか
明けましておめでとうございました
持っているほどうるさくないですってかもっと
迷惑をかけてもいいんですよみたいな事までいただいて本当にありがたい環境で動画を
撮らせていただいているところを持っております本当にありがとうございます
ですが僕は
新しいよ
見つけてしまいましたいいのかでいきましょういっぱいではさっそく入っていきま
しょーううわあ
はいもう結構音が入ってるんですけどこんな感じでございます
奥行きがすごいですどうでしょ
結構奥駅があるというヒロイン杏に新しい4つ入ってラリーもうで家具とかいろいろ
入れまくったねちょっと今ゴザを出してるんですけども
新しい本ずでございます実はまだまだ部屋があるんでちょっと見ていきました
もうね何がすごいかっていうので
ここですよここからねしたが見えるようになってるんですよ
めちゃくちゃ押されポイント町で公が明ければ猫からね
なんか下に人がいたら何かモノをガーンでできるっていう
なんかもうユーチューバーというか僕にとっちゃ最強のシステムが完成しています
どんどん行きましょう
ではもう一つの部屋はこちらですうーん
もう家具が正空も9分照明とかも置いてるんですけどどうすかマルチカー
そう
あっはっ
バッハ
パッはぁ
いやが寄せこのパとすることカーテンなんか
このこの感じを受けてかするカーテン連動された照明
椅子いかがでしょうかここが僕の新しいを打つです
すごいでしょう
どうでしょうかまだ部屋があるんですよこっちにもまだ部屋があるんですよ
見ていきました部屋数も多いからすごいんですよねここはまだ真っ暗
ないと付かないでねじゃあもうまだ何も置いてない状態なんですけども
カーテンだけすごいキレイなんですよね
tan
me
ん
なんだったんだ今なぁ
goo
はぁんっ
管ああ
なってものいいえ
あっちゃあかんだよ
なんなんだこの家
[音楽]
お前なんなんだよ誰なんでお前
tan tan
[音楽]
この家はあのちょっと目た
ぽくなっちゃったんですけどもこの日は
本当にもらいましたん
まあ賃貸なんですけどねあ猫の絵実はですねあのあのお世話になっている大江さんから
ちょっと相談を受けましててがアドバイスというか提案みたいのいただいてあの
もう一軒
使うと言われてや正直すごくありがたかったんですよねそのうまい棒で家もアフで人が
増え
もうなんか1やワイヤーの状態でまああの家も広いちゃえばいいんですけどもう
ちょっと初めはみゅーずめんとパークのキャパをオーバー防ぐなって思っているときに
大家さんからのありがたいお言葉をいただいてこの家
実は大家さんが昔使っていた工事でございます今は全然使っ
ていないみたいなんですけどもだからその家具とかちょっとあの僕の僕だった選べない
ようなちょっとフェイスのいい感じのカフェがたくさんなっていってまぁとりあえず今
はこのままなんですけどもあの子の家を変えることになりました
実質家2つ持つですねあの東京にも家があったと思うんですけどあそこですね契約が
なんともうすぐあと1か月で切れちゃうんでまた東京です場所が僕はない
になってしまいます何でもなんかそれはそれでまた東京に行った時に中とか知らない
知らないまあダメです知ってる人のいいとが止まったらいいなと思ってるんで
まあそれはそれでなんとかなると思いながら静岡の拠点をもっとで描くするためにこの
家も借りたので
まぁちょっとどう使うかは今後を決めていきたいんですけども始めたかもチャンネルを
ちゃんとやりながら
新参でもできればいいなと思ってお
いますじゃ